HENRY:
Our legacy isn't how many commas
we have in our bank account.
It's who we're looking up
to have in our lives.
And what we can
lead them with.
Henry!
Remind me again why we can't
put you on a gifted school.
'Cause it's better for
my Psycho Social Development,
for me to interact with the peer group
at a normal school enviromenmt.
[WHISPERS]
Oh, yeah.
[Music]
Hey, Susan. I guess I can just send it
over Direct Deposit, if that's easier.
I-I don't know.
I'll have to ask Henry.
You have to ask
your eleven-year old?
Did our Financial Statement
come in the mail, today?
Yeah, I forgot to
give it to you.
I don't know how you do
it, all by yourself.
Come on!
I have Henry.
Find me another Male of the species,
who's more grown-up than him.
I'd like to.
The story,
is about me,
my brother, my mom, and
the girl who lived next door.
Henry and Peter,
they're lucky to have you.
And your fathers lucky
to have you too.
Stepfather.
- You okay?
- Yeah, I'm good.
Mom, I have to tell you something
and it's very important.
Christina's in trouble.
When someone hurts someone else,
we have to make it better.
There's only one
way to stop it.
I'd hope to do it all myself,
but that's not an option.
There has to be another
way to help Christina.
Why, there's no
way, to help...
Mr. Sickleman, is
the Police Commissioner.
I'm not gonna subject him to public
scrutiny without conclusive evidence.
[WHISPERS]
Okay, let's do this.
Mom, everything you
need is right here.
I'll be with you
the whole time.
I know what
you've done.
And we documented
all of it.
Who do you think
they're gonna believe?
It can't be
left undone.
- No matter what, don't panic.
- I'm not panicking!
We have to
make it better.